[Music]
all right this is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
okay crazy yeah so far hundreds hundreds
of challengers not one winner
we don't make mistake I really don't
think we do we don't know perfect in
every way
gods among men I think is what they call
it yes
yeah this is gods among men yes that's
the name of the show so tonight tonight
a fan named Joey gia Lombardo says he
thinks he caught a mistake he says it
happened when I was talking to celebrity
chef Giada De Laurentiis here he is hey
Conan huge fan but I found a mistake in
one of your episodes in a cooking
segment with Giada dealer ATIS after you
accidentally pull the lever off of the
pasta roller you said that you had never
used one before okay this just came off
is that a problem no I'm just kidding oh
it's supposed to move around I have no
idea I've not used one of these cranks
so there you go well that's a lie and I
have proof in a cooking segment on your
show from 2006 with chef Gordon Ramsay
you use a pasta roller you even go as
far as to say that any idiot could use
one so Conan loved the show but you made
a mistake better own up to it this time
[Music]
and that guy is mad yeah I'm just
curious hey are you mad at me or you
just mad that you were kicked out of
limp Biskit anyway I am sorry he seems
like a hardcore fan right I want to show
him their respect but I'm sorry Jia
Lombardo you're the one who's dead wrong
I really had never used a pasta roller
before that's because in 20 years on the
air that Gordon Ramsay episode that you
referenced is the only show that I
missed I missed one show and that was it
you see that night I took a lucrative
private engagement I was flown to Libya
to perform for Muammar Gaddafi's 64th
birthday party I made a ton of money
yeah yeah it was a pretty good guy even
though I was out of the country we had
to air a show that night so they created
an entire Late Night with Conan O'Brien
episode using only CGI only time it's
ever been done I wasn't there that was
CGI here's a behind-the-scenes look at
how that amazing show was made hi I'm
Steve Robinson graphics artist here at
Conan I'm the one who created the CGI
episode back in 2006 let me take you
through that most viewers that night had
no idea they were watching
computer-generated images based on
motion capture technology but they were
let's go back a step
mistook ours body movements facial
expressions but the process didn't start
there let's take another step back
here's the raw data we got from the
motion capture cameras an essential part
of the process now let's see the mocap
actors themselves here they are our
Conan and Gordon
amazing performers super fantastic
[Music]
and after that night we never use CGI
again isn't that right Andy that's right
Conan never again nope you can't make
chump meat out of this maestro we'll be
right back with that Shepard